2017's celebrated adaptation of Stephen King's
It is now out on DVD and Blu-ray, and there
are plenty of deleted and extended scenes
to savor.
In all, there are 11 added segments included
in the film's bonus features, so, let's run
through what's new and how the new clips fit
into the overall story.
And of course, here's the all important spoiler
alert for anyone still waiting to get spooked
by Pennywise.
Fake out
The first scene included in the bonus features
is an alternate take of that iconic opening
moment when little Georgie Denbrough chases
his prized paper boat down the rain stream,
and it gets sucked into the sewer drain, where
Pennywise the Dancing Clown is hiding.
But instead of having his arm ripped off and
being dragged into Derry's dark water, in
this version he simply grabs the boat and
wanders off, saying:
"See ya later!"
Pennywise's reaction to Georgie's unexpected
escape?
First, it's silent confusion; then, he finally
utters:
"Ah s---."
Dad guilt
Next up, we have the scene with Stanley's
father chiding him over his lack of preparation
for his bar mitzvah.
We already saw him correct his poor pronunciation
and remind his son that he's the rabbi.
But in the extended version, he goes for broke
with the guilt trip.
Not only does he essentially tell him he needs
to take responsibility for his soul, but he
also rattles off a list of exactly who he
stands to let down if he messes this up.
With that kinda pressure looming on the home
front, it's no wonder Stanley's the most burdened
of the bunch.
Family friction
One thing that seemed to be a little lacking
in the theatrical version of It was the emotional
toll that Georgie's disappearance would take
on the rest of the Denbroughs.
In a new scene, though, we find out that not
only are they completely broken, but it's
Bill who's being inconsiderate and aloof about
everything.
His mom is shown silently laboring over the
dishes, as his father reads a magazine and
Bill starts prattling on about planning their
annual summer park trip.
His mother wants nothing to do with it, and
storms off, and that's when his dad informs
him that it's not happening.
This was Georgie's favorite trip, so it doesn't
matter how much everyone else liked it.
It's done.
Second skeptic
Another scene that's extended is the one when
Bill flees from the basement after seeing
a phantom Georgie and Pennywise down below.
"Bill, if you'll come with me, you'll float
too."
He runs into his father upstairs and explains
what he saw, which prompts his father to explore
the room right away.
Even though Bill can clearly hear his dad
sloshing around the flooded basement, his
dad still returns to report that it's "dry
as a bone" and that it must have been a bad
dream.
Like other clueless adults around town, his
dad doesn't see or hear what's really going
on, and thinks it's just a product of Bill's
cruel imagination.
Grown ups.
Unhappy home
An aspect of the original It story that's
mercifully glossed over in the cinematic adaptation
is the abuse Henry Bowers suffers at the hands
of his alcoholic father.
In a new scene, though, he's shown struggling
to apply ointment to lashes on his back, implying
he's been whipped by his mean old man — and
that this isn't the first time.
Upon Henry's attempt to the leave the house,
his father demands that he fetch him another
beer first, and he complies without any ounce
hesitation or attitude.
But by the time his friends arrive, Henry's
back to wearing his tough guy air.
"That fat f--- knows if he touches me I'll
rip his head off."
As they're about to leave, too, they spot
Mike Hanlon passing by on his delivery bike,
which sets up the quick scene with Mike being
bullied by the trio as Pennywise looks on.
Fighting fear
Stanley's emotional defection from the rest
of the Losers is also evident in a new scene
from the Neibolt House, when half the Losers
play lookout.
Stan cries to Mike about how he doesn't want
to go in the house, and it's clear he just
can't handle what's happening to all of them
right now.
Meanwhile, the scene also sets up a pretty
tender exchange between Ben and Beverly.
As they wait for the others, he places a hand
on her shoulder, and she reciprocates by placing
her hand on top of his own.
An exodus
The next scene is only a slight extension
of the Neibolt House scene that scared the
hell out of everyone in the theaters.
But in a new piece of the sequence, we get
to see how the group reacts to fighting their
way out of Pennywise's clutches the first
time.
With Eddie's broken arm, he has to be carted
away on Mike's bike, ditching his own ride
in the street, and they're all otherwise in
a collective state of panic as they scramble
to flee the scene.
Seeing their post-battle fear in action like
this, it's pretty clear why they might be
so quick to disband.
Moody monologue
Stanley Uris might be a shrinking violet throughout
the film, but he gets one scene of serious
retribution in his bar mitzvah monologue.
In the extended version of his ceremony, he
lays into his father and the whole synagogue,
by calling them out for being out of touch
with the dangers around town.
"Becoming an adult, according to the holy
scripture of Derry, is learning not to give
a s---!"
Perhaps not surprisingly, the only one who
claps for him is Richie "Trashmouth" Tozier.
Cast vandal
In another briefly extended scene, we're finally
shown what Eddie's face looks like when he
realizes that Beverly's bully has signed his
cast with the word "Loser" down at the pharmacy.
And to make matters worse, we also see her
tack her chewed up wad of gum on top for an
extra dose of germaphobia.
Slaughter session
The most shocking added scene of them all
features Henry Bowers, now possessed by Pennywise,
parked outside the Neibolt house with his
face covered in blood.
He watches as the Losers prepare to go in
and attempt to rescue Beverly from the clown.
"Like lambs to a slaughter."
That's when the camera pans to the passenger
side and we see that both of his sidekicks
have had their necks slashed, presumably by
Henry's newly reacquired knife.
It's then that the Losers enter the house,
not knowing that they have a twisted Henry
lurking behind them.
If included, the scene might've taken away
the element of surprise when Henry shows up
and attacks Mike, but it may have also set
up the eventual excuse Derry folks adopt about
all the deaths, as they pin them on Henry.
The walkie talkie
In the theatrical version of It, Bill Denbrough
doesn't get a real sign of his brother's fate
until after they vanquish Pennywise.
But in an extended version of the scene, he
stumbles upon Georgie's walkie talkie first
thing.
Considering the condition of the device — it
appears to be unbroken and perhaps even functional
— the find might've given him false hope
about his brother's condition and caused confusion
in the final fight.
So it's probably for the best that the filmmakers
let him have his big showdown with the clown
before handing him Georgie's old stuff.
Family vacation
The original film ended after the Losers said
goodbye, but the alternative version of the
closing moments would've ended on a slightly
more optimistic note for at least one character.
The unused ending included in the bonus features
shows Bill's parents packing up the station
wagon, as his mother comes out to kiss him
and say they'll make new memories with a new
vacation spot.
Now that they've all come to accept Georgie's
fate, they're finally starting to heal.
But just to make sure no one gets too cozy,
the camera eventually pans to the storm drain
that was such a problem for them in the first
place, just as it begins to rain.
There's no Pennywise in there — yet — but
it's clear his reign of terror is far from
finished.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!